[Musique]
la pandémie de covid 19 n'est même pas
terminée que déjà une autre maladie se
répand dans le monde la variole simienne
une épidémie sans précédent plus de
57000 cas d'infection ont été rapportés
dans une centaine de pays depuis le mois
de mai si la propagation du virus semble
ralentir à l'échelle mondiale les
infections continuent de grimper dans
plusieurs régions de la planète ma
collègue Gaëlle duchaberdou nous plonge
dans cette histoire qui commence dans
les années 50
[Musique]
la variole simienne qu'on appelle aussi
variole du singe ou mankipox en anglais
a été identifié pour la première fois
dans un laboratoire danois en 1958 chez
des singes d'où son nom
mais elle n'est pas unique au singe
c'est une zone ose une maladie qui se
transmet des animaux aux humains et elle
peut affecter plusieurs mammifères elle
a été diagnostiquée pour la première
fois chez l'humain en 1970 en République
démocratique du Congo
c'est un virus qui est un proche parent
de celui de la variole la variole c'est
une maladie souvent mortelle qui a été
éradiquée à la fin des années 70 grâce à
de grandes campagnes de vaccination
la variole simienne ressemble à la
variole entre autres parce qu'elle cause
des éruptions cutanées douloureuses mais
elle est en général moins grave et
jusqu'à maintenant elle était plutôt
rare depuis les années 70 la maladie a
surgi ponctuellement en Afrique mais
elle était rarement sortie du continent
et jamais pour se répandre commencement
alors pourquoi maintenant ça fait déjà
plusieurs années en fait que des experts
s'inquiètent que la maladie ne puisse
prendre de l'ampleur d'abord parce qu'on
sait qu'être protégé contre la variole
protège aussi contre sa cousine la
variole simienne
or depuis les années 80 on ne vaccine
plus contre la variole puisqu'elle a été
éradiquée aussi des cas de variole
simiennes ont été détectées à
l'extérieur du continent africain au
cours des 20 dernières années dont une
petite éclosion aux États-Unis en 2003
en 2017 au Nigéria la maladie s'est
propagée de manière plus soutenue
qu'attendue avec une transmission
d'humains à humain plutôt que d'animal à
humain plusieurs cas de varioles
simiennes ont été rapportées depuis dans
différents pays chez des voyageurs qui
revenaient du Nigéria y compris en mai
dernier au début de l'épidémie actuelle
à partir de ce moment-là la maladie
s'est répandue un peu partout au Canada
comme ailleurs elle touche
essentiellement des hommes qui ont des
relations homosexuelles mais le virus ne
fait pas de discrimination il peut
contaminer n'importe qui
selon les données de l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé l'OMS près de 2%
des personnes infectées sont des femmes
et des enfants ont aussi attrapé la
maladie la variole simienne n'est pas
très contagieuse elle se transmet
surtout quand on entre en contact direct
avec les lésions d'une personne infectée
ou avec ses fluides corporelles si la
communauté homosexuelle est
sur-représentée parmi les infections
c'est probablement parce que l'épidémie
y a pris naissance et que ses membres
ont plus de contacts rapprochés au sein
même de la communauté qu'en dehors
cette transmission liée majoritairement
pour l'instant à des rapports sexuels la
rapidité de la propagation du virus tout
ça est inédit ça a pris les experts de
cours et ça soulève beaucoup de
questions sur cette maladie jusqu'ici
méconnue
[Musique]
devant la situation l'OMS a fait de
l'épidémie une urgence de santé publique
de porter internationale un de ses
objectifs c'est d'accélérer la recherche
et la production de vaccins et de
traitement contre la maladie pour
l'instant les moyens qu'on a sont
limités au Canada on a un vaccin contre
la variole simienne c'est un produit qui
en fait été développé contre la variole
pour prévenir l'éventuelle retour de
cette maladie disparue on sait que les
anticorps engendrés par le vaccin sont
efficaces contre le virus de la variole
simienne mais on n'a jamais vérifié à
quel point dans la vraie vie il protège
contre la maladie
en ce qui concerne les traitements c'est
un peu similaire le Canada a approuvé un
antiviral contre la variole et autorise
les médecins à l'utiliser contre la
variole simienne mais on ne connaît pas
vraiment son efficacité par ailleurs les
quantités de ces vaccins et traitement
sont limités un peu comme pour la
covid-19 l'épidémie de variole simienne
a provoqué une accélération de la
recherche mais contrairement à la covid
ce n'est pas une nouvelle maladie et
pour les plus critiques c'est dommages
qui les fallut que son histoire déborde
du continent africain pour qu'on s'y
intéresse vraiment
[Musique]